if Ikea is the global face of Sweden
Walmart might be America's
but despite apparently being one of the
country's most patriotic Brands over
half of all Walmarts are located outside
the United States
it's 10 500 stores are scattered across
24 countries 46 Brands and four
continents from Botswana and El Salvador
to these strange and exotic lands of
Ohio
Target on the other hand operates in
just one country
in its entire 120 year history it only
once tried to expand overseas
in a mere two years Target opened over a
hundred stores and Canada failed
spectacularly and became a textbook 7
billion dollar example of what not to do
it was such a disaster in fact that
someone wrote an actual two-act play
reenacting the events
it was even performed in one of its
abandoned stores
sponsored by nebula the platform created
owned and loved by creators
sign up for exclusive early and bonus
content from polymatter and hundreds of
other channels you're guaranteed to love
the Greek tragedy known as Target Canada
begins with a company called Zellers
non-canadians can think of Zellers like
a colder more polite version of Kmart a
large national chain of discount
department stores
and like Kmart it was by the early 2010s
more of a 90s Time Capsule than an
actual store
but to its credit rather than merely
watch as its brand slowly aged into
inevitable bankruptcy like a certain
company whose name rhymes with Spears it
threw in the towel and sold its only
asset that still had value land
the Zeller's name may not have meant
much but it's nearly 200 leases
certainly did
meanwhile Target was rapidly approaching
saturation in America
after nearly two decades of eight
percent average growth only 10 new
stores were built in all of 2010. and
where better to expand to than its
friendly Northern neighbor the one just
225 miles from Target's corporate
headquarters
besides the obvious cultural and
linguistic overlap about 300 000 people
cross what is the longest border in the
world each day
the company estimated that one in every
10 Canadians had shopped at an American
Target during the previous year
besides many U.S corporations have done
well up north
of Canada's top 10 retailers by Revenue
five are American
this was not all of this is to say a
crazy idea
with similar demographics pre-existing
brand awareness and relatively few
cultural differences Target Canada had
everything going for it
the only thing holding it back was the
size of its doors
there just aren't that many one to two
hundred thousand square foot buildings
with pentagon-sized parking lots
then Along Came Zellers
this was the opportunity Target had been
waiting for
in 2011 Target paid 1.8 billion Canadian
dollars to buy 189 Zeller stores 54 of
which it immediately resold to other
companies including none other than its
good friend Walmart
there was however one major catch
from the moment the deal was signed the
Clock Was ticking
Not only was every day spent cleaning
Remodeling and renovating these stores a
day it wasn't making money but Target
bought only the leases not the land
outright
they still had to deal with landlords
landlords who weren't too keen on
letting these huge buildings sit empty
or Worse bustling with construction for
years on end
to avoid deterring Shoppers from other
stores in the area it all had to happen
fast really fast
bringing these retail museums into the
21st century required more than a Fresh
coat of paint about 10 to 11 million
dollars worth of work for each location
still Target trudged ahead on what it
called project bacon starting with the
launch of three Ontario stores in March
of 2013.
their signs which read were open mostly
hinted at the disaster soon to come
for the next 10 months Target opened one
new Canadian store every two days on
average
it was the quickest expansion in company
history a feat that continued through
2014.
but first Target had a serious problem
it wasn't a lack of demand Canadians
were eager to give the company a chance
the problem was a lack of inventory
shelf after shelf sat totally empty
one week almost every item featured on
Target's promotional flyer was out of
stock
with nothing to buy it's no wonder
targets Canadian stores sold far less
merchandise than their American
counterparts
it all traced back to a single decision
made months earlier
and to understand why we'll need to take
a brief detour into everyone's favorite
dinner table topic the wonderful world
of enterprise software
and it's only right that you hear this
in the form of a PowerPoint
huge billion dollar Mega corporations
such as for example EG Target are simply
too big for any one person to keep track
of
so naturally they turn to computers more
specifically something called Erp
enterprise resource planning
you can think of Erp like the mother of
all Excel spreadsheets
for the kids an all-knowing All-Seeing
notion dashboard
your company's Erp system knows how many
fractions of a cent it costs to ship
this lamp from Distribution Center to
store how many different colors this
couch comes in and at what exact point
to reorder more dark blue oversized
throw blankets based on the time of year
recent sales and diesel prices
simply put Erp is the brain of a giant
Corporation
Target already had its own custom Erp
built for America but it was designed to
work only in English with US Dollars
inches and feet
so rather than trying to jury rig its
American System Target opted to start
fresh to buy a new Erp called sap
spoiler alert this was a terrible idea
now back to your regular scheduled
programming
to Target Executives this sounded like
the best most sensible long-term
decision better to rip off the Band-Aid
quickly by switching to the software
used by all the Fortune 500 companies
the one trusted by Disney and Burger
King and Coca-Cola
to anyone in the tech industry however
this was an obvious recipe for disaster
the first thing to understand about sap
is how it makes money
like many enterprise software companies
it's just as much in the Consulting
business as it is in the writing
software business
in fact providing support can be so
profitable that it's not unheard of for
companies to give away their software
for free
this for instance is Sap's third quarter
2022 investor report
you can see that at least 38 percent of
its Revenue came from software support
anyone who's Ever Had The Misfortune of
using enterprise software knows the
secret when the people Executives who
buy the software don't themselves use it
it sucks
but because sap also makes a huge chunk
of its money from support it's even
worse
how much incentive do they really have
to make it easy to use
now the point is not that sap doesn't
have its uses there's a reason so many
companies buy it
when Erp systems work they can do things
no human could possibly do
and if sap weren't Dependable Disney
wouldn't be using them
but for them to be Dependable the data
you feed them has to be perfect
garbage in garbage out
and by data we're talking about the
width height length color weight
quantity description price and so on for
every last one of the 75 000 unique
items sold by Target
now add French an entirely different
system of measurements and a new
currency to the mix not to mention the
difficulty of learning to use sap and
you can see how this was fundamentally
incompatible with Target Canada's
extremely tight deadline
software famously is finished when it's
finished even on the best of days
deadlines schedules and road maps are
just wishful thinking
implementing an Erp is no different
however long you think it might take add
a couple years and congratulations
you've discovered the best case scenario
sobies Canada's second largest
Supermarket gave up on sap despite
spending 4 years and 89 million dollars
after its databases were shut down for
five days
another company's transition took two
years longer than expected
so you can probably guess what happened
when Target Canada tried to do the whole
thing in two years
complete unmitigated disaster
[Music]
while it stores shelves sat empty
products piled up in distribution
centers Target had all the inventory it
needed it just didn't know where
eventually the company was forced to
rent extra storage space
it soon discovered the culprit a mere 30
percent of the information entered into
the system was accurate
the other 70 percent might be measured
in inches misspelled or simply missing
faced with no other option the entire
Target merchandising team spent days
manually verifying the information for
all 75 000 products
on top of this analysts whose
performance was measured based on their
ability to keep products in stock had
completely turned off the automatic
replenishment system so they wouldn't be
penalized
Target wasn't just Flying Blind its
gauges were feeding it false information
how could it possibly take off
successfully under those conditions
now as bad as this was and it was bad it
probably wasn't fatal
Supply chains are just plain hard and it
always takes time for companies to
acclimate to a new environment
nor was it any big Scandal that targets
prices were about 15 percent higher in
Canada
the country is about nine times less
densely populated than the United States
which makes it much more expensive to
get products into stores
every last item for all 133 stores was
sourced from one of just three
distribution centers in Milton Balzac
and Cornwall
the latter therefore had to ship
products as far away as St John's
Newfoundland a 1600 Mile 33-hour Drive
and ferry ride away
not to mention fuel is more expensive
than Canada
but for prices to be visibly higher and
for shelves to be routinely empty with
simply a stretch too far
by 2014 Just 18 percent of surveyed
Canadians said they were very satisfied
with the company
above all though the true fatal flaw in
Target's plan the real root of its
problems was the deal with Zellers
had it tested the market with one or two
stores to begin with like J.Crew or
Nordstrom did it would have had the
necessary Focus to correct any speed
bumps and learn from them
instead Sparks soon turned into a 133
store forest fire it was too much too
fast
it also didn't help that many of these
stores were in subpar locations
when it entered Canada Target wasn't
Tarjay it was a Fresh coat of paint over
a former Kmart
all the shiny bright red spheres in the
world couldn't make up for the fact that
these buildings were situated in Rundown
strip malls and sea class shopping
centers
the company lost 940 million dollars in
the first year alone and the problem
only compounded from there
so after a widely publicized data breach
followed by a couple of lackluster
holiday seasons the bread and butter of
retail Target Canada looked for an exit
and on April 1st 2015 just 757 days
after the first store opened Target
announced it was leaving Canada
despite spending seven billion dollars
hiring 17 000 employees and taking over
133 stores it left with hardly a Trace
this was the Zellers liquidation sale in
2011 and this was the target liquidation
sale possibly at the very same location
just a few short years later
one store in Ottawa was completely
finished but unopened at the time
the pristine untouched Target was sold
to Walmart along with dozens of others
and Canadians 75 percent of whom live
less than 100 miles from America quietly
went back to crossing the border
it was as if one of the biggest
disasters in retail history never
happened
one thing that I hope will leave an
impression is my video debunking the
myth that China lifted 800 million
people out of poverty this persistent
myth has been used as a sort of get out
of jail free card by the authorities in
Beijing there's a dark history behind
this claim one that would surely get
demonetized on YouTube
and that's precisely why we created
nebula the streaming platform built by
and for independent creators
there are no ads videos like mine are
available days earlier and you get
exclusive access to content that will
never air on YouTube
content like my six part series China
actually Neo's under exposure or re-life
floors modern conflicts
personally I checked the front page of
nebula several times a day and I'm
Amazed by how often new exclusive
original content is released
all these came out in just the last few
weeks for instance
now normally nebula costs five dollars a
month but you can get it for just half
that by signing up for a year with a
link on screen or in the description now
that's just two dollars and fifty cents
a month for loads of exclusive content
you'll love